if you go up on the ranks three four
five no one wants to fight me so
I'm 35 I'm not getting any younger yeah
you know and uh and I have two goals on
there I want to become a champion and I
want to fight the best guys whenever I'm
done
I want to be that guy that I look at my
record people looking like wow that guy
for everybody so if he's the most he was
that guy I want to fight this guy you
know I want to fight let's see if that
guy's a real monster and uh that was my
reason why getting that fight when you
say you wanted to fight the who's who
you look at your resume you've kind of
done that I mean you said you want to be
World Champ and you know I think you'll
get there but it's also like here's
close man uh sorry dude didn't work out
here's Wonder Boy and it's like God damn
but that's but that's where you're at
and then you beat Wonder Boy and then
it's like here's Hamza